to our Los Angeles slugs do we have an
announcement for you we are doing our
second official trash Tuesday live show
because the first one was so fun it was
unbeliev it was like the Lord came down
our listeners are like the funniest
weirdest weirdest best people so we're
doing it this year for Valentine's Day
February 13th same place same time at
the region theater at 8:00 pm get your
tickets get your sweetheart the tickets
for Christmas we cannot wait it's sold
out last time get your tickets now guys
and also don't you can travel come
travel and see us we had a lot of
Travelers last time we really did though
we sold meet and greet tickets we had a
fun meet and greet ahead of time it was
so F Q&A was so great it was so it was
so crazy it's very rare to get all three
of us at a live event together it's only
happened once before this is the second
time and we can't wait we'll see you
guys there and can I just tell you guys
what the VIP experience is like you
actually just get to sit with the three
of us to chat you can ask us anything
there aren't any restrictions it's such
a sweet time to get to know each other
there's no cameras so we just say a lot
more yeah if you can imagine and we deny
anything you guys said we said will we
actually never said anything we said we
said no they're lying they're liars and
where can we get tickets oh the lincol
bio guys it rules we're not it's like I
can't even believe what happened last
time there's a link below get tickets we
can't wait there will also be limited
edition merch available at this show
just like last time it sold out like
that so we can't wait knock out your
holiday shopping today and get 20% off
your first order plus free shipping at
meundies.com TR Tuesday that's
meundies.com sltr Tuesday for 20% off
plus free shipping meundies comfort from
the outside in sluggy sluggy sluggy I'm
so excited this weekend I'm going to be
in Houston Texas at the Houston Improv I
love me some Tex Texas baby so come see
me uh I also have my next Annie wooden
friends at The Comedy Store December
21st then you can see me in Canada and
Edmonton January 12th and 13th I'll be
in Jacksonville Florida January 19th and
20th I will be in Denver Colorado
February 16th and 17th Vancouver for the
festival uh February 21st to 22nd and I
will be at the DC comedy Loft in March
so go to Annie letter.com shows for all
those ticket links Portland announcing
this right now I am doing one of the
last stops on this tour in Portland and
Seattle those are the last two so
January 18th I'll be in Portland and
January 26th I'll be in Seattle and
January 7th is my rescheduled San Jose
show I cannot wait to see you guys there
you can get tickets at Esther and
ice.com and I'm so
excited Esther is that an opal ring wait
I can't how did you notice that I'm I'm
obsessed with opal Australian opal is
like my my thing is it because it looks
like go go on my back on that picture
you tell me I can see I like never think
twice about opal but this is okay so you
know how I told you guys like when my
grandma died my dad gave every last one
of her belongings away to like all the
other relatives she was like I'm never
having kids I'm never getting married
travesty which is like okay fine but
recently I got a text from like a long
lost cousin who was like
a relative of mine passed away and she
was passed down this ring from her
grandmother who was given it by your
father basically so in Chicago my show a
relative brought me this ring now did a
relative know that you didn't get any of
did they hear you talking about not
getting it or was it just no but when
they told me I was I literally poured
out my heart I was like you have no idea
how much this means to me I've been
searching I like I just she was like
okay I was going to give it to you
anyway I thought you were going to be
like are you a slug and they're like
what when you ask someone if they're a
slug and they're not a slug they're so
confused they're like what they think
you're calling them that does seem like
really insulting it's not good wait can
I tell you something about opal that I
that I learned um when I dated um a
jeweler um the reason you have to be
really careful with that is opal is a
lot um more delicate than other
gemstones so they the reason that I
never got an opal ring and I always op I
want an opal necklace instead is because
I don't want to break it cuz you use
your hands a lot is it valuable opal is
very valuable have you ever seen black
Opals okay this is no I this is probably
like $300 but Opals are you should get
it a just to know but that's what
someone said to me about emeralds too is
that just what every Jeweler says so
when they break your stone they're like
that's actually they're actually more
delicate than others can I had to give
up the dream of quite possibly having
the best engagement ring like ever when
I broke up with a jeweler cuz that could
have been a really really there's more
Jewelers there's more Jewelers I know
but it would have been specific there
would have been Coral from like the
[__] 1500s or some crazy like kind of
fun to think about your ex's and like
what are the perks that you're the
random perks that were not worth holding
on to but like you kind of Miss I always
think about like if my ex's I did a post
once where it was like the tiniest
diamond ring I'm like if my ex had
proposed like like the tiniest you're
like it's like the little like baby like
one of these earrings like put on a oh
that's
cute thanks I just scanned my brain and
I can't think of a single perk that one
of my exes provided that I missed so I
never mind on that subject I was
thinking about your ex's well I can't
imagine do you have any yes um so my ex
um was a math teacher but now is like a
high school principal was that good for
role play no he was more of like the
accountant of the home like when we were
together he was someone that kind of
like still balanced his checkbooks and
I'm like who the [__] does that like not
online or on their phone that's like
such a weird thing my mom and stepdad
still do yeah it's very grandfatherly
yeah so he he had those things where I'm
like oh that's maybe sometimes what I
need in my life wait you dated a high
school principal yeah yeah she was in
high school no I know that's I know that
she was 16 years old we you went all the
way to the top to the principal I did I
did I shot I shot for the moon like
imagine though you're in high school and
your principal rolls up and like you see
Kila as his girlfriend like every kid
would be like damn I know they're like
oh my god oh know and he was really
goodl looking oh really so they all
wanted him probably like he's really
good looking not that that's an excuse
to hook up with them yeah yeah yeah it's
not like we had did you guys I was like
I don't know why I'm like I like I'm
victim was the teacher hot I know this
is really um um might be triggering for
you Annie but was there anyone like Hot
for Teacher were you ever Hot for
Teacher or a teacher in your high school
there what was her name we'll get to the
hot for student in a sec Annie there was
a teacher that like everyone thought was
hot but you know me it's like when I
know I have no chance I try to just
sweep it under the rug but there was one
teacher that was like do you deny their
hotness when you know you don't have a
chance yeah but then there was this
really really old teacher oh my god
really old like Mr zagi shout out from
still have a shot don't mean to hurt
your feelings no I know but like no can
I tell you something we like had a Vibe
he was literally like 88 like he was the
only teacher that like like older sister
had him and you know she's 8 years older
like there was just he was there forever
and we like there was like a vibe there
was a playfulness she had him when he he
was 80 yeah he was old for so long but
are there any X perks that you ever had
like a good oh I probably could have got
like a really beautiful it's not an opal
but it's a black eye I probably could
have it's like I wouldn't have done my
makeup it would look so like dark and
Smoky um I think I could have it's like
I literally it's almost like a black
opal really I had it's it's the closest
to jewelry got some Shimmer in it it was
almost like if they did it often enough
it would be like getting a tattooed
eyeliner on um I had a boy who was uh he
was a boy at the time he um we were like
in our early 20s he was an artist and it
was like cute he painted Landscapes it
was kind of boring like sometimes there
were people in them I was like is that
me like sitting and eating a picnic with
so you like enjoyed his artwork at the
very beginning I was like this is cool
and then I was like uh but he came to
Santa Fe to visit me once and he brought
all of his paintings like he was going
to like all of a sudden become a person
that advocated for himself and like go
to like the art galleries a lot of Art
and then he left and we broke up and
then I just had his paintings so I
dropped it off at an eBay drop off store
and I was like figure it out what if you
find out if you watch like five years
from now you're just randomly watching
Antique Road Show and someone has
brought in those paintings and they have
somehow miscalculated and upraised it
for $6 million I'll call in and be like
guys this is from 2008 oh so you would
you cancel it well he would be getting
the money so so if someone else would be
but wouldn't you be happy for them and
just let it ride I would be happy
sometimes when my like when I lose my
credit card and it gets charged I go a I
would it seems like it's such a
victimless crime wait wait wait but what
are they buying though what would they
buy where you're like and what what
would they buy where you're like oh [__]
no if they spend like $100 at the dollar
store I'm like oh they're getting
Christmas presents for everyone okay
that's sweet that's sweet it's always
the dollar store I've had a lot of
Walmart charges for like beauty supplies
and stff
I had to I had to check like I'm every
time I see them I'm like obviously this
could be me but no there was some stuff
like that oh isn't that so embarrassing
when you're like this isn't me and then
you like look in oh that was me that
happens to me a lot that's what happened
I just checked my venmo transactions two
days ago and I sent money to a person
and it said not important I was like who
the [__] is not important that was their
name on venmo and I I called my sister
and I was like hey check my chart is
this is [__] shady or whatever and it
turns out they low no I tipped I was
drunk and I tipped a stripper directly
to her venmo a huge amount
single-handedly keeping the strip
stripper Community like alive thriving
during the holiday season
single-handedly going to a strip clubs
without us over and over again it's like
getting so crazy about the stripper
though wait better have not been in La
you cheated on us this is like you just
telling us someone you cheated on us no
this is I will not say where it is cuz
will give it away but she's from El Paso
Texas and I'm telling you I've never
seen a girl that like skilled on the
pole I have fallen you know I've fallen
in love with strippers before me too
that's spent hundreds and hundreds of
dollars sending her a ven is it hard for
them to catch the money when you have to
go up at them down in your small small
statue I don't I'm not a stage Tipper
I'm like I buy dances and like we go we
go behind oh a true lesbian oh wait guys
guys I went to okay Robbie Hoffman um
had a birthday party slash party for her
premiere of her she did a 10-minute like
hilarious 10-minute set on Netflix I
went and it was just like a bunch of
lesbians talking about like they were
bringing their sex toys out and stuff
and I was like she is now Robbie Hoffman
is now dating Gabby Wiley who is my
favorite B of all time yes they are
dating this is her first lesand
relationship they're like going to get
married they're totally in love but they
were talking about sex in a way where I
was like Todd we need to Dyke it up in
the bed like this is crazy like they are
like lesbian I'm sorry Lesbos I kind of
thought you were just like cuddling a
lot no I wrong and here's another thing
they're really good at after care Oh pre
care after care everything in between
care everything it's a whole experience
I did have a boyfriend that was really
good at washing my dildos like he was
like you're gonna get an infection cuz
I'm like Let It crust up I'll I'll I
wanted to crust up so I can just bang it
on the table and kind of fall off yeah
like Christmas but um but they like
brought out they have a dildo that's
like you get like cumy Lube it's like
come yeah yeah and then you can it and
it comes julan and it was I just was
like and they were like are you do you
strap or do you strap they're like I'm a
switch I'm like I'm a switch I'm a
switch and um I was like I want to do
both I want both I just was like Todd we
have to like really like how could you
lesbian ify your sex life I wonder I
think just like even more toys and just
like switching roles and like one of you
know what I mean wait I need to tell you
guys something that I have like been
wanting to share but it's like so sad
and I it's it's like okay so I did not
know this but when you're pregnant and I
don't think this is everyone no no
no when you have an o r g m sorry you're
a gone gone we call that your uterus
like literally immediately after like it
gives you these painful cramp
contractions i l the day after I found I
tested positive back in July you know I
was alone in a hotel room I did my thing
and I literally was like for Co you've
had Co so many times that's what I
thought you were talking about that is
how I revealed it to Dave I was like I
tested positive for pregnancy um but it
was so painful that I'm not kidding you
guys I have not had a single sexual
interaction with myself or with anyone
out on the street are you are you horny
no but the craziest thing is happening
for the last couple months I would say
like three times a week I have a vivid
sexual dream where I'm just like I just
got to get off I've never experienced
anything like this and it's so sad like
sex has been taken away from me but do
you think that wait till the baby's
there um but do you think that you're
having these sex rooms because you're
not having as much sex as you usually
have it's got to be right like it's got
It's coming out somewhere yeah because
the desire is gone when I'm like but is
a desire gone Bas because you're afraid
of the pain after orgasm I think that
was like the kicker and then it's also
just like I feel so not like a sex
that's so sad we all feel the opposite
I'm so sorry you feel what you've never
been hotter really hot really did you
see my comment I almost felt bad
commenting because it was too real and
there's probably too many people that
agree but I was like currently
developing a pregnancy fetish I mean
look we already know got the most likes
of many things I've posted in a long
time we we already know about my
ChatterBait history so let's not even
get into don't act like we know that
much okay you weird stranger your belly
I mean it's a it's it's a hit never been
more must be then like a physical you
and you also you I know you guys know
this I think it's about weight like uh
how you look and how much money you have
it doesn't matter what other people
think about it's only what you what how
you feel cuz you can come in here and
say I'm this and that I'm fat whatever
but Annie it doesn't matter that's why I
never say when a girlfriend of mine is
like I'm fat I'm like I stay out of it
cuz I don't want to like is it is that
wrong no you know what it's kind of this
is like a little bit of a segue but I've
been thinking a lot about I really since
I did IAS this last time really want to
like be organized with things and I'm
like trying to really like time block
and be organized all this stuff and I
was talking to her she works with people
with the ADD and she's like yeah but
don't be hard on yourself and I'm like I
want to be like it's not hard on myself
it's just I have come risen to the top
of being like a sloppy [__] like I'm
the number one sloppy [__] in town like
I have R I am the creme de La Creme of
like throwing it together and having it
work out but now I want to try actually
like setting up a goal having a deadline
finishing and feeling the reward of
finishing a deadline but everyone almost
like talks me out of that and they're
like no no no like you're being hard on
yourself so I'm trying to really balance
like what's self-discipline and what's
like being hard on yourself me that is
interesting cuz I like last week or a
couple weeks ago when I was talking
about like how I did punishments to like
not flake on things and then I remember
you brought up like oh I don't want to
have consequen to be hard on myself but
for me if I don't have the consequence I
just don't trust myself I you know what
like I can't be like oh gentle Esther
like you'll do what's right like it's
just that doesn't work this poor
baby are you kidding Dave and I are
going to be like grandparents I think
that's our my prediction for us we're
going to be like grandparents raising a
grandchild I think having older parents
is going to make us like because we're
just through a lot of it already if you
want your baby or child to see nature
can I strap it her onto my back and just
take her around anytime you want okay
cool you on the other hand you don't
think my shoulders could hold the baby
just cuz her shoulders are a little bit
broader than we have an extremely
important follow question what is that
eyes Shadow it is um it's so the right
amount of glitter in 2023 it is so good
I just got it it's Urban Decay of course
Ur course I love Urban Decay their
eyeliner and I have the eyeliner too
eyeliners are the great there's one
shade of green that they discontinu
which I thought was like the best one
it's sort of like a lighter green they
don't have it anymore but I'm really sad
about it will you send a pick of it and
then we'll post and it's I also use it
as highlighter and everyone keeps
thinking I have botox it's so cute guys
I just I'm shimmering up yeah I've just
been everyone's like what's your makeup
I'm like I am just over highlighting
[__] I also use the Fenty like red um
like shimmery highlighter and that's
almost like a blush Fenty is legit I
love Fenty
bronzer my makeup artist friend swears
by her I friend FY a friend I don't have
a makeup artist know my makeup friend
you guys don't you think it's time since
we've had a lot of new sluggy um come
into the show and come into the slug
Community shouldn't we like reintroduce
ourselves whoa we haven't done that in a
long time why do we reinvent ourselves
that I've done that we do that for the
new year can we do that for the new year
I'm there I'm doing it I'm literally
becoming a mom M wait it is so
weird it honestly is the weirdest thing
ever the first time you found you were
pregnant I could not have been I was
like cuz she was like I think she's with
child I was like with child what the
hell are you talking about the child is
with child she's two feet tall and so
this time I like not that I need to be
prepared for you to be prepared but I'm
I'm so down I'm so like not shocked I'm
so excited oh my God but how okay wait
how would we reintroduce ourselves and
how would we reinvent I'm into both of
these just our new knew who we're going
to step into I love that but we should
do that but no end of year okay
beginning of year or whatever do next
also the origin story of the slug I
would people are asking about that I
believe I think it started because Kila
was talking about having slugs as pets
right no I think it was no I had was
raised by slugs that was the so that was
the first thing was Kila played with
slugs and then you were like made a
connection to that's me like you turn
you were raised by slugs like I imagined
you being raised by slugs wait this has
nothing to do with snail Trail no sadly
I think they all add in oh my God see
this is what I'm talking about the
misremembering yes it's like you create
your own origin story in your head I
thought maybe we were talking about
snail Trails you thought that this was
because I had AET it that I want to say
talk about how you just said create how
how do I say create create no also you
know what create [__] you're right it's
create it's create I like that though no
you you take it you like like these are
two words create and eight create eight
I don't misremember [__] everyone [__]
science don't here's the psycho here we
found the psycho the group everybody's
been wondering there's been a ball like
you know when there's you know there's a
sing along and there's like a ball like
who's the psycho of the group this ball
has landed I know when I remember and
when I don't and what I do know for sure
and we can cut back find the old episode
it was very early on you said you were
talking about having having a pet Slug
and you a pet noodle I never had a pet
slug that's why that's where we're wrong
I've never had a pet
slug play with slugs you play with SLS
and then maybe I went yeah well you were
raised by them cuz I just imagine you as
like living in like a little colony of
we should acknowledge the fact that yes
I did have a pet noodle and it was a
chow Noodle and I tied it to a string
and I um dragged it around for about a
month that's why she cries when we go up
for Chinese food and truly oh she's like
you're eating my pets eting dogs and I
named and then one day my sister stepped
on said Noodle and my pet um can I ask
you a question that might get us in
trouble
yes sir doctor um why is there like the
sort of like racist Trope that Chinese
people eat dogs I don't think it's just
China either I think that Asia in
general there is like a culture of
eating whatever available protein there
is at least for me like I can't answer
about Chinese or Koreans but in the
Philippines even growing up that's
something that we would accuse people of
doing You' be like oh don't eat don't
don't eat that like that's dog or cat
meat and that's something that we were
told as children and what I later found
out was because of my drunk uncles that
they would get drunk they would get
hungry there was no meat around because
they live Mur each other but aside from
murdering humans they would
unfortunately no do this find a dog and
like and kill it
this would devastate me as a kid I'd be
like why the [__] are you doing this and
so those that's as far as I know I know
it's not something that Filipinos do
it's just something that has been told
to me as a child that maybe my uncles
have done well if you think about like
the the kill shelters it's like maybe
they should Annie me people with the
dogs no Annie they just throw the meat
out no we're just no killing oh oh I
don't think they should kill but I mean
it just exists no guys don't kill dogs I
like how you said throw the meat out so
already it's well once it's done should
it's only meat for like 20 minutes I
have a question should we not extend
that to humans then too or anything that
everything that dies but don't we get
sick from eating humans make it spam
just ground up the meat who cares it's
mystery meat you think there
is for the rest of the pregnanc and
you're the one with human meat in you oh
right now thank God though I'm not
making a penis that's really helps me
sleep at night that baby's probably
going to make a out of you when it comes
out what do you mean just aftermath
being God Esther we have some fun news
for you this week okay okay I'm going to
change the slide it's breaking news
breaking
news oh my God I saw this someway
announces foot long cookies yes I saw
this it okay I got obviously initially
excited and then it just got sad because
pregnancy has made me not enjoy food as
much and so food is like it's just a sad
subject but can I say Dave needs to
bring one home for each of us and he
cannot get a 6 in for himself and also
even bigger fast food news have you guys
heard of cosmic what is cosmic
McDonald's for the first time is
launching like a side New Concept of a
restaurant and the first one is opening
in Bowling Brook Illinois which is only
an hour drive from where I grew up and
like people are leaking the menu
basically it's a new they're basing this
New Concept on like one of their 80s
robot characters so you know how Grimace
like blew up this summer well there's
this like I don't know that Grimace blew
up this summer I Grimace at the thought
to be honest I'm horrified of what I've
been missing on Tik Tok okay so it's
based on one of their 80s characters
like good for McDonald's blowing up you
know their old IP really like making
using every part of the Buffalo but
someone found the menu and it has like
all these cool like sour cherry blast
drinks that like make no sense and are
just pure poison poison and sound good
and then they have like s'mores cold
brew it's going to be this revolutionary
new McDonald's concept that probably
close in two years but I'm very excited
I love that they're not just making it a
healthy restaurant I love I was just
saying pivot in to the towards the wrong
direction yeah it's like why wouldn't
you just I was just talking about this
before you guys got here like that it's
like if fast food restaurants really had
health like a truly healthy menu we
would they would blow up because you
have choice
they've tried it though everyone why
they take it away do you not miss the
salads from McDonald's I do of course
iers they were the best but the problem
I think they were giving us salilla no
Julian talks about mcak talk about M
shakers all the time do you go there
with your makeup artist friend you
friend um you know that MC shakers had a
higher calorie count than a Big Mac we
all remember we all remember the the
early
2000s horrible truths look at how Chic
this restaurant looks that
it doesn't look Chic this is sad you
have pregnancy eyes have I have a seg um
so Subway is um doing a footlong cookie
coincidence because I just saw um Julie
shot yes and she has this purse that you
know I've never been a purse girly right
like you guys talk about purses and I'm
always like don't know and now I am
fixated on this one purse and it's a
very simple it's a very simple purse
it's by puppets and puppets and it has a
it looks like a 3D cookie attached to it
can you pull up like cookie she is Asian
guys it's official and I don't know if
we're allowed to ask cute fans for gifts
this Christmas if anyone would love to
send this to me that's right not I don't
want the mini I want the small that's
really cute and if you keep scrolling
it's a 3D cookie it's
545 that's really cute it's an actual
cookie I like they have an egg and they
have a banana one as well banana one oh
my God we need the banana one Julie Shaw
always knows the coolest things do like
ahead of everyone she's the founder of
starface Julie the um morning after pill
that we love and I've used a lot in um
my months of being single in her month
hased me in her months of accepting
Opals and then she also just launched
like a thing to help kids stop vaping
blip yeah oh I just started vaping um
interesting and it is for kids okay so
are once you taste the flavors you're go
this is for children really yeah it was
like botox or vaping oh wait what do you
mean I was like how do I look young no
but this is so true because like my
friend's do my friend just caught his
daughter um vaping and she's 12 and she
was vaping with her friends on Snapchat
like that terrifies me f kids vaping is
scary because their bodies are they
can't handle like you can handle Vape
you can't you was a with a kid's body
and a kid body like you could do
anything and like your body will just
stay I'm sturdy I was born sturdy you
are a hearty hearty Oscar fish I'm
hearty I've never called myself hearty
but I like it feels good no I was told
by a celebrity doctor I won't name his
name we know him um that I I said I want
to do something bad he goes all right I
go can I Vape he goes and I by the way I
called him at 3: in the morning his time
not even thinking I was waking him up
and he was like what do you want I was
like oh I just want is vaping bad and
he's like yes not as bad as cigarettes
but bad and I was like oh I was like I
want to do something bad and he goes you
can do it for two months and then what
happened at two months I
stop I'm good at that yeah that is I
don't have that skill I'm good at that I
it's really hard it took me 2 years to
slowly quit weed so that took 30 start
yeah I know you guys is this a crazy
idea yes
okay 100% is this a crazy idea and I
have not told Dave this idea yet so he
will be finding it out when he literally
spies on us and listens to this I told
you I caught him listening to the Angela
White episode of course was it
masturbating no but it's like Dave why
is that the one you're listening to day
of that is the when I was listening in
the car cuz I usually when I I watch it
you know and he listens to it and I was
like oh my God we're all that's when I I
think I texted everyone I was like we're
all so different cuz on podcast I can
never tell the people apart but on this
one and maybe I'm just biased cuz it's
us but it's like yeah of course every
like who's that dude it's not David so
it's me it's Annie
but so okay is this a crazy idea I think
that when we have our kid I want to have
no alcohol in the house ever ever like
and I never want Dave to even and I feel
so bad because Dave is the healthiest
most normal Drinker like a glass of wine
a couple times a week he has his own
little wine fridge even but I'm thinking
like I grew up in a house where there
was never alcohol no one drank and that
had a I believe had a positive impact on
me so some could argue otherwise but
they you're a real weirdo yes that is
also the very fair argument but I'm
thinking I want to tell Dave like no
alcohol in the house once the baby's
like okay the only thing I would say
would be like a red flag about that
would be if he then would feel like he
would have to sneak and then all of a
sudden you give him an an alcohol
problem you you in turn have somehow
given him a weird
sneaky in the like instead of being on
his phone while he's pretend taking a
[__] like you all guys all of you guys
do you would have the worst hemorrhoids
if you were literally [__] for that
long um we know what you're doing you're
escaping us he's just in there just
sipping is why you ripped the door off
the bathroom in your guys the door is
there because I want him to be making a
choice I don't want I want to know that
my man has left it
open okay Esther I think that as long as
you're not imposing this no alcohol and
you're not so obvious about it
organically don't have alcohol CU you
don't drink and Dave is an infrequent
drinker but I think that there is
something to be said about your child
like observing Dave drinking very
moderately and very responsibly once in
a while but like I I do think that I
don't also want my kid to think that
cracking a beer open every night having
a beer and having wine with every dinner
is something that's normal yeah because
that has happened in my family and it in
like my extended family and it has led
to some real issues and again I but I
also have no judgments of drinking like
as you guys know the moment I tried weed
I didn't stop eating and ingesting it
for 2 years like literally not one break
in fact some nights I'd be like oh my
God it's 10 p.m. I haven't had any weed
today but I'm about to fall asleep take
20 milligrams like just to like keep
that was me at like last call when
people call last call at a bar I would
lose my mind I would be like shots shots
oh my God I'd be like call what the hell
are you talking about that's why I think
the 2 a.m. cut off is so dangerous
because I I was exactly like you where
it's like I'm like I'm about to get so
[__] up and then you're making me
leave and it's going to hit me while I'm
driving home that sounds so funny while
I'm driving home officers it's your the
government's fault no don't say that you
drove home that's so SC it a scooter
though SCS to prove it it was a scooter
though right have you ever just had a
scooter just ruin your life I mean I
just ruined your titties but guys it's
cute we reconstructed wait okay we put
them back together Humpty Dumpty is
driving high like okay drove on a
scooter what's no my God I was just
checking I was just tricking you C's
okay C's okay do you have this with your
guys like I feel like this is like a
dude thing where it's like he gets drunk
and then he like insists tries to insist
on driving like I never let him but I
always have to have such a serious
conversation like where I have to like
grab the card Tesla card and and I have
to be like I have to be like I have
built this beautiful life do you know
how hard I work to have the best life
ever you are not shortening it like we
are not dying we are not getting a car
accident we're not killing anyone
and then I drive home and then I do have
to think on the way home like it might
have been safer with him drunk me sober
yeah I don't know I can't promise you
yeah that we wouldn't have been safer
Dave never gets drunk I I but I have had
those moments with friends and I love
those pep talks it's so fun to give them
Dave I rarely ever get to see him high
or drunk but when I do like you you best
believe I'm like trying to like extract
information I'm trying to trick him and
get him to agree to things like and then
he record she has her contracts she has
a file cabinet of contracts he is so and
he just like Giggles it's I love it I
wish you now I'm like [__] we'll have
the alcohol in the house I want him to
be drunk all the time but I do think
there's something to say about not
making a big deal about things making
things normal huge and when I was a
babysitter for like literally like crazy
crazy Rich Beverly Hills families when I
first moved here it blew my mind they I
walk in the kitchen every candy every
cookie everything everywhere and I was
like we never could have this in my
house and the mom was like you just have
it out so that it's not like special
like whoa that is that is how I felt
about buying um seaweed salad from
Costco so I used to be obsessed with
seaweed Sal [__] skinny [__] what an
annoying it's it's the concept of always
eat
seaweed salad is really sweet though
delicious it's so good so like you know
when you go to a sushi restaurant they
only give you like a small amount but
they pack it underneath they pack it
underneath with some [__] but they
keep you wanting more and you're like
what the [__] so what I I'm like I love
seaweed so much it's such a healthy food
so then I bought it at Costco once and I
got a big [__] tub of seaweed salad
I'm telling you it rotted in the fridge
I no longer wanted it it was too much
and it was like well it's just there it
didn't excite me anymore so I think
there is there is something to be said
there but sugar is a drug so be really
careful with that that's like intuitive
eating like where you're supposed to
just not have anything be good or bad
and you're just like my parents and I
listen to that it's like we were too far
gone for this concept we listened to it
on like a road trip we probably were it
was probably like a Thanksgiving or
something we listened to it and all we
heard was you can eat whatever you want
and we gorged and binged like binge
eating with my parents is what I have to
say binge eating with my parents is one
of my absolute favorite happy places in
the world obviously it's a nightmare
when it starts to digest and still
shoving food down um at one point this
Thanksgiving I had eaten so much food
and my mother-in-law just kept cooking
more she cooked lemon boy which is
London broyal but she kept calling it
lemon boy I was like she's like I still
have lemon boy lemon boy we're like what
the hell is lemon boy Todd's Todd's
brothers and they were like we just
always thought it was called lemon boy
we had no clue so I'd already stuffed
myself Todd and I were going to get
alcohol for the family I took like a
handful of it she cooked it rare for us
I I shoved it in my mouth meat by the
hand yes [__] meat by the hand don't
act like you're better than me um I was
I was as stuffed as you but I was like
chewing it it was like so chewy and Todd
was like I cannot believe you just did
that he's like this is cuz I'm already I
was already in like the sweats and the
moans and like yeah but you got to go if
you're already there then just go full
suffering she so happy when I eat her
food yeah now you got to go full
suffering it's like look if you've
already like destroyed your body destroy
it some more it's also so fun when you
eat a lot and then people are like whoo
like that makes me want more point right
like how far can I really take this will
I die tonight like there are moments
where I'm just like I've gone too far
but how much further can I take it is a
really good test of like it's it's sick
but I will say this about intuitive
eating I also came upon it a little too
late because by the time I was I needed
I my sensors are all off so there is sa
and when I'm supposed to know
intuitively that I'm hungry but I'm like
I've never once eaten for for Hunger
I've eaten for a taste like I'm somebody
who chases tast taste all day Kila I
have not been hungry in 25 years I don't
know I it's a foreign concept to me I
don't know what it is I am thrilled to
eat it is like there are no bad foods is
a huge concept that I took from when I
went to like an eating disorder like
30-day treatment program and like Dave
and I always say that now like there are
no he'll be like is this unhealthy I'm
like there are no bad foods because that
has lifted the naughtiness cuz you guys
are right once it's naught it's so fun
you want to that's what made my dad do I
told you guys when I went home a couple
times my dad picked me up from the uh
airport and I was like yeah I've been
fasting and like doing this he's like oh
your mom and I we've really been like um
dieting a lot and I go oh cool and they
goes Chinese I go yeah Chinese and then
we like immediately went got Chinese
food it was so fun and then so I look at
it it's like is it bad if it's like this
source of joy and I think about when my
parents are gone and I bing I'll they'll
be bingeing through me yeah we will
together it'll be like my bond to them
and Dave who I consider to be very
emotionally healthy he's always
encouraging me like eat enjoy food like
he doesn't have it's also saying like
slow down but I just I think that's like
beautiful that's sort of what I love
about I think I mentioned this before my
trainer my trainer is not the reason I
love Marlin Marlin Fernando is because I
know exactly what he looks like from
that name he is so like good about like
rehabbing like my injuries and stuff he
just doesn't put any pressure on food
he's if anything he's just like don't
forget to eat right have you had lunch
are you making sure like you know like
making just saying hey you need to eat
you're nourishing your body I know how
hard you work so it's like I he's the
perfect person for someone disordered
like yeah I like telling my trainer she
doesn't shame me or anything but she's
not like good job but I'll just text her
I'll be like oops I just ate Peanut
M&M's in the hotel it's 4 in the morning
but it's like whatever who cares I'm
obviously feeding something at that
time no it any time the worst time ever
the whenever I'm doing the worst with
food it's when I'm trying to restrict
it's when I'm like holding back but as
soon as I'm like have a eat Esther fill
up you were I'm good you were so funny
when I did the um Master Cleanse you
were like
oh Bo that's another thing I learned in
my eating disorder training like the
pendulum will always swing back so it's
like if you think you're killing it by
like under nourishing yourself the
pendulum will swing back and you will
have to refill was fun the treatment it
was fun it was me and a bunch of
anorexic teens it was really fun I was
there for Bing eating disorder the food
good we brought our own food and we had
to like prepare our own meal it wasn't
sleepover no it was uh eight hours a day
oh that's pretty inp partial
hospitalization program was embarrassing
mine was a combo of all three it was OV
ex exercising losing my toenails that
way like running 13 miles a day and then
I'm going on Extreme what what they call
it's keto now but it was Atkins so I
would count calories in like ketchup and
so restriction and then binging so it
would swing back and forth between like
anorexia being like not eating at all
over exercising and then breaking right
cuz the pendulum would swing and then
the B then the purging then the vomiting
and everything I feel like very lucky
that I never had like it never felt like
my health was in danger I feel like so
bad for people where it's like they're
really seriously like in danger but I do
think we were talking about earlier I
did um Weight Watchers with my mom and
it is like a fun B memory it was like a
fun bonding experience with my Mom
especially if you fail together it was
so fun like we just had so much fun like
counting our local doing little like
points together they had like this
little book back then yeah there was
like a book and you would like open it
right and but they had this thing you
could like like a little like clicker it
was just so cute I don't know I I always
think about like when my mom and I would
like bleach our mustaches together like
all these weird little things my mom and
I did together were so were so fun so I
guess I'm trying to think about it all
like that like I've had a lot of fun in
my disorder my bleach mustaches so I I
got laser down there for the very first
time really I really I really had to
consider this because I was like What if
I want to hide behind a bush one day and
I can no longer grow one right it
doesn't last I've done it it doesn't
stay you seen yeah have you seen news in
shorts okay so all the hairs in the
front have fallen off but my [__]
hairs are hanging on talk they are not
going anywhere anytime soon and I like I
had told the lady I was like hey make
sure you spread it and you zap those
[__] cuz those are the the
stubborn ones it hurts so or it's so
itchy to shave your ass too and it's the
worst thing to shave and you know before
you laser they make you shave I haven't
shaved since high school like I've
gotten waxed and so this was a really
uncomfortable thing for me and now I
think my [__] has never been bushier
I listen that you migrated it they just
pushed it over I will say this I'm so
glad you're bringing up waxing I got
sugared yesterday my day off was all
about my [__] I got a colonic and I
and I waxed and I set it up so that I
would get wax first first it was I was
getting colonic first and waxing I was
like oh that's G to [__] everyone over
I'm GNA have an ass Bush for the colonic
girl and I'm going to [__] on the
[__] sugar ladies thing so I switch I
flipped them and then I was thinking
when I was getting the sugar in cuz it I
waited so long that it was like a virgin
waxing again it was like I had never
done it that's right and it was so
painful that I was like I first of all I
was sweating I was like I was in fight
ORF flight I was like I literally feel
like you're a tiger chasing me in the
woods like I feel like I I feel like I
literally feel like I have to protect my
family right now and then you get a high
after but it took a sec well don't worry
the colonic took the highway but um but
as I was leaving I was like you know
what they should have they should have
like like lollipops and stickers like
when little kids go to the dentist like
there should be like a cute reward when
you're done watching your [__] that's
actually doesn't hurt that bad it's that
top an [__] doesn't hurt at all I was
like am I bruised like how did this my
girl's so funny that's why I loved going
to the doctor when I was little because
our hospital had a
McDonald's and so like the doctor was
just getting McDonald's in my mind my
stupid child brain that's smart yeah
don't give it to
me take it me take your banana what you
want me to take your banana home maybe
I'll take it okay oh wow Mama Bear came
out my baby want I just
during banana break this weekend you
want it you can't have
it you guys my new favorite underwear is
officially me undies comfortable just
got the cutest colors like I got like a
burgundy a forest green like they're
very they're like my holiday panties for
the season they you know what my
requirement is in all panties a cotton
gusset I need a gusset the fact you guys
know what a gusset is called is so wild
to me I need it because it you know it's
keeps my pH in Balance let's just say
that I need the softest material
possible and meand delivers that this is
where I hide my
money that's what that's for that I make
when I'm wearing them but they have from
all black Classics to fun expressive
prints I like cuz they're like one of
the only brands that makes like cool fun
prints you don't see that a lot and also
it's like it is very like my mood
changes sometimes I really want to feel
very pure and Lacy and white as long as
they're breathable which meundies
definitely are Mundi Fabrics are light
they're breathable to help regulate your
body temperature so you stay cool and
comfy down there they also no they also
have really comfy loungewear like they
have robes and joggers and stuff which I
think is you can't go wrong with like a
really like soft high quality Lounge
piece for anyone on your list and
meundies is like definitely my go-to for
that they're so soft that guys even when
you're like picking them up to sniff
like they're very nice on your face Mees
are sustainably sourced and they work
with partners that care for their
workers a knock out your holiday
shopping today and get 20% off your
first order plus free shipping at
meundies.com
tday that's meundies.com trash Tuesday
for 20% off plus free shipping meundies
comfort from the outside in we also
today are here chatting about our
favorite merch drop our holiday
collection so excited this baby blue
shirt I've been wearing pretty much
every day exclusively everyone loves the
color everyone loves how soft it is Dave
asked for one so we need one in a large
for him this crew neck is I wear this
around the house with nothing underneath
and it is so comfy I have it in an extra
large um and this has just been my life
this has been my daily wardrobe really
the col it was my it was my um my
Thanksgiving outfit and you look so cute
in the baby love this hoodie so much and
the boy slugs wearing this is you guys
look so hot a pink hoodie with three hot
asses cute hot and sexy or all of them
okay keep tagging us we'll repost you we
love seeing you guys in the holiday
collection it's limited edition once
it's gone it's gone and we can't wait to
see your tags and you guys can get it at
it's TR tuesday.com
are you dancing while pregnant I took 40
minutes of a b class this weekend there
was a huge deal and a valet
class they're like no back up back up
that's what K needs for parallel part
honestly imagine if like tomorrow you
guys hear me saying like please I don't
need to hear any jokes about this I
don't want to hear any judgment but I am
in valet school and I'm learning to
valet cars because I'm really because of
how we shamed you yeah you shamed me
about my um why don't you just go to an
eye doctor I don't think it's you know
I've I think it's the relationship to
space that you have I've been at
restaurants where men just pull up and
hand me their keys cuz they think I'm
the valet so it's not totally off like
is that like a teenager's job I don't
know what it is I do have that though
where everywhere I go people think I
work there like it does not matter what
I'm wearing I could be in Target in a
green shirt and people are like are is
there a restroom here ma'am I'm like
what I I think it's just I look yeah no
I no it's not that it's because most
women in La like look put together and
we go out as we are and so people just
assume we work everywhere I think we
look like billionaires I always think
like the like shittier I dress the
Richer I look in La you know that that
cool bar break room 86 in K Town I was
there once like years ago and I remember
I walked in I'm like every woman is
wearing a skirt I'm the only one in
pants and then this drunk girl
immediately comes up to me she's like
could we have some more cups I'm
like did you get them for don't be a
[__] can we talk about the what's on
the table Yeah so it's this sixth night
of Hanukkah tonight and my true love
brought to
me yeah you can light the manora I made
you guys some homemade lkas oh it's not
l l Lis is like the ashkanazi way but
yeah latas oh then L askanazi I'm ashash
so there's applesauce and sour cream um
and then little Hanukkah plates for you
guys and then there's also sparkling
cider did you bring us any gelt [__] I
tried about it I tried there's it's
difficult to F no no which no it really
is for no you're not vibrating on a
Jewish level and you just don't see
Jewish thing hard to so you know I
started seeing somebody right who is
like amazing incredible like I actually
think there's a path forward for us
super excited about it gender
reveal this isn't a gender reveal but
there is still that part of me that
really wants to have a threeome mhm and
I have broached a topic with him and
basically said like hey would you be
down for this it's like with a guy with
not with a guy not with with another
girl basically it's like it's easy to
just be like okay well you know you
could just like hire a sex worker right
and come in and they already know what
to do or whatnot but for some reason
that do isn't quite as appealing for me
as someone who is like wants to be
unicorn yeah who also has that fantasy
of being like I want to really join a
couple but you want to have you want to
have a continued relationship with them
yeah like I my thing right now is I want
it to be I don't want a one night stand
I'm very specific about what I want I
want this is has to be a person that I
can go out to coffee with not quite a
sister wife who has all the perks of
their relationship but someone who is
like whose company I genuinely enjoy and
someone who can who wants to have sex
with me and my boyfriend once in a while
these plane tickets are going to start
getting expensive bringing both of them
back and forth from Hawaii those going
to be wild [__] but do you know what I
mean is this is that too much to ask for
someone who's just like oh okay like
it's sort of like a halfgirlfriend would
you ever go on field I was on there and
it was a Miss for me all around because
I feel like field is very like it's not
Mrs Fields we're not talking about so
you're not interested it's like high on
Kink and like for me I want something
relatively normal like I want normal
relationship with the is this confusing
she I'm laughing at her eating her
cheese while you tell this story why in
a different world than her right now
having a different life I'm fully
invested you're having but she is having
a threesome right now basically but I
guess you can't K I think that that's a
pretty unique take I think so you would
have to find someone that like would be
cool with it because if I was a third
like I'd never want to I don't know if
I'd ever want to like hang out with them
okay so Sam because like the idea of me
personally being unicorn by another
couple makes me want to run away like I
feel like it's so icky to be like oh
yeah she's our unicorn but it's no like
I genuinely want a situation where it's
like she is she likes being a part of
the trio but like in she she's in a
situationship with us but him and I are
in a wouldn't you get jealous if you she
was spending that much no no but that's
my Kink right like I my Kink is watching
the person that I love experience
pleasure not for me wow okay well okay
so this is just boundaries so it's and
it's also like you're dating it's not
it's like every other like dating
situation right so it's like you're
going to have to like find the right
Vibe with people you're probably going
to have to try out some people and see
who fits you can't just like or maybe
you can't maybe the first person will be
a
complete how to find her I think you
should keep going to strip clubs and
find someone that you Vibe with and that
you have a crush on and then like find
someone that you have the hots for in
person in real life not on an app and
you know maybe not through a friend like
through something completely separate
from normal life so it's it's not going
to be someone that's like in your
day-to-day ever but someone that you can
have this relationship with that's
outside of your inner circle and I think
a strip club just because like beautiful
women you'll get like turned on by
someone and it might take a while but
maybe maybe they won't want it but you
can just kind of Court you know go yeah
you just have to have boundaries and be
open and just you know yeah I do wonder
how it's going to um play out and it
doesn't have to be like the super
long-term thing where they're like
committed to this it's just I just I'm
not into one night stands they terrify
me I need to get to for even for me to
be attracted to someone there has to be
a connection this is a real thing
Remember Jay Jordan was talking about
how he his relationship had a third
member of the relationship had a
boyfriend yeah they had a boyfriend they
were a married couple with a boyfriend
and then the boyfriend he they were
pissed cuz the boyfriend like ran off
which is like so funny and I love it and
I get it but like so this is this is
happening what you're saying yeah I have
a
I don't know if they're slugs or just I
think they're probably fans of all of us
but they come to all my shows and
they're they're poly but they had a
girlfriend and then one of them broke up
with a girl and the other one's still
dating her oh they were like a threesome
and now it's just like a twosome and
Tome what's the genders of the original
women all women oh but they're so cool
I'm sorry I forgot your names you know I
love you [__] it's just this is very
it's a lot more common I think than you
than you think honestly like this is a
very especially in Los Angeles I know
that it's super common in in in gay
marriages but even like even
heterosexual marriages like I have a
friend he really enjoys getting pegged
he enjoys is this like your makeup
artist yeah the makeup artist friend no
it's not but they brought in another I
mean it's a they're a married couple but
they brought another guy and they ended
up just like hitting it off so they just
have it then I have another set of
heterosexual friends who both have a
significant other on the side so and
they enjoy listening to what that their
partner did with their significant other
that's super hot my ex-boyfriend had
that with his ex-girlfriend but he was
didn't actually like it and then he kept
trying to get me to be in one and I was
like you I already saw what happened
yeah you the same page I'm never really
going to know how it feels until I let
it rip rightt like you got to just let
it happen and then it could be where I'm
like actually you know what I don't love
this situation and I'm feeling X Y and Z
about it but it's okay I'm adding an
extra layer and this might be
ultimately um what stops me is I have a
kink for really successful women if when
I imagine you're out eser when I
imagine um a um someone coming in as a
third I imagine her being like making as
much as me um being just as busy with
her life having a lot of things going on
that's super attractive I want you with
like a like an architect that like does
like development in my Miami like I met
these women in my IAS like they are like
such badasses like like you need like
yeah a woman that's like top of a game
but they might have like a whole family
honestly there's do you know what I mean
like [__] that handle [__] have like
families too there's so many amazing
successful hot women that are single
right now cuz all the men suck like
sorry that's just what people say and
that's not my opinion um but it like I
think this is achievable but also do you
need her to be single so if she as long
as she's not in some really messy open
relationship cuz I think that but I
think I would prefer it if she was
single well Dave and I are bringing a
third in I'm excited to hear what you
end up naming your girl have we thought
about this do you know already I love
how it's have we thought about this I
think we have the name I think like I've
known Straight Out The Gate what it is
like Dave pitched it a long time ago and
he's a writer so he's like wanting to
rewrite and like pitch new ideas and I'm
like it up I'm like we got got it trust
me we got it but I'm open to hearing his
pictures but I'm like we got it okay so
during the Angela White um episode um we
talked about or she talked about not
knowing what dating means and I think
that we couldn't really come to a
consensus either as a group so we went
to Instagram we um surveyed um the Slugs
and we have results dating 48% say
dating means we're exclusive but not
official
36% say dating means casual sex and some
dates and only 16% say it's official and
I've met the family wow so we're kind of
just all over the place no one knows
what the [__] we're talking about dating
is I met the family no way but you know
what I've said I've dated a guy and he's
met my family and it's like where am I
am I talking to someone where I don't
want to like get into it too much I'm
like yeah the guy I'm dating and
wouldn't you say the guy I'm dating just
met my family I could imagine saying
that it's like you don't want to say
names I think it's like you just went on
the third date and you're like that it
just keeps getting better and better
we're dating like yes that's it to me
it's like a waffles rule yeah I agree
wouldn't you say exclusive is like
that's my boyfriend that's no cuz
exclusive just means you've agreed not
to sleep with other people but you
haven't quite put the label on it you're
in St in Filipino courtship this is the
stage of mutual understanding oh no
she's mad Mutual understanding so it's
not you can't talk to me like that we're
not
dating so I I get this um but I have
used the term dating for when I first
hook up with a guy all the way to till
he meets my family you call men boys too
you're you just say thing yeah it's just
it doesn't matter yeah you're the boy
I'm dating yeah the boy I'm dating it's
like whatever they don't like that very
much I find out we the the men men don't
like that the guys were dating the boys
were dating no where I'm like oh I met a
boy if I refer to them as like boys
they're like like they don't say
anything about it I say it so
endearingly I always say like you're so
cute and I had a boyfriend who was like
stop calling me cute and I'm like cute
is the highest form
just like I like [__]
love oh you're so cute cute is way
better than handsome like handsome is
like maybe I'm not even into call him
sexy guys I'm going to be honest there's
definitely moments when getting called
cute is like I hate getting called Jesus
Christ well guys cute talking to the
wrong people over here we got you guys
are too horny cute is great I can not
call a man sexy really no I'm sexy I'm
sexy yeah that's like all I say that's
so funny about men Yes Men I say you're
it's not working out twice divorce bed
that's the problem I'm not calling them
cute no I say hot a lot and sexy hot is
good I W go where's my handsome I'll go
like where's my handsome guy and
sometimes I'm talking about Randy I
think hot is probably perfect it dep
like I'm like who am I talking about but
would you look in the middle of passion
would you be like oh you're so cute no I
would never I'm saying I think's cute
for everything good like I'm like that's
so cute this is so cute my friend with
somebody that she's like you always say
everything's cute I'm like cuz that to
me is like my highest like excitement
that's adorable yeah I mean I wouldn't
be a cute calling him cute while he's
eating my [__] of course I used to you
have to understand I'm just like
becoming a grown-up right now and I'm
I've just gone through all my trauma to
become like an adult and so I my
fantasies used to be like I used to have
to pretend that we met at we went to
different high schools but we were like
and we met at a party but we were in
high school and we were like hooking up
on like a couch downstairs like that was
like where I was at so I standed so like
a cute boy like I met a cute boy like
that to me is like the top I get it yeah
like if you want to get my pants off
like call me sexy but not you guys I'm
talking to I don't know why I'm talking
to Todd but if I'm like giving you cues
to call me sexy it's when I'm calling
you cute I don't even want sexy is like
90s to me it's sex but hot is what I
mean to but I mean hot yeah Todd when we
were first dating he like crawled in
like Leonardo DiCaprio like on like like
that was very good and you should do
that more beautiful is also nice no
gorgeous but you guys I made fun of on
Annie what I made fun of we made fun of
how Todd's dad always calls me gorgeous
and puts fire emojis and I was like did
I even post a picture if I don't get a
Gorge old man but here's the thing I
love it and I'm so flattered by it and
now he doesn't do it cuz we shamed him
and I'm so sad there's an absence in my
life it's confusing to be with us sorry
guys another poll what's the other poll
so when venting to a guy friend what do
you want them to do how do you want them
to respond okay I know exactly what I
want them when I'm venting about a guy
my friend Schmidt did it and he's like
why I ended up dating Todd he would go
I'd be like this guy is like not texting
goes oh you mean a guy can't handle how
strong and and gorgeous you are he can't
handle being with a woman like he
literally flattered me so hard and then
he was like you know who you should date
is Todd and that's how I got with Todd
he buttered me up for Todd but I used to
take Todd out and complain to him about
guys we would go that's how our
friendship started and Todd would be
like he'd have just nothing to say he'd
just sit there while I vented which is
what our relationship is now okay so 74%
said just lets me rant and agrees with
everything 22% helps me fix the problem
that's definitely me I want always want
help fixing problems um and 5% want them
to zone out which is also kind of good
both so there are times when I need help
where it's like hey I'm coming to you
for
Solutions or I'm coming to you because I
just need to get this off my chest are
two very different things but I think um
I think it's really important too like
if you're the person who's listening to
kind of say like hey like what like how
can I like what do you need right now
like do you need answers do you need
Solutions or do you just need and when I
just need to rant please just let me
rant yeah like I just need to get it off
my chest unload because I already know
the answer I just need to process it
with somebody that's such a waste of a
rant to me really I'm not ranting for
free I want help at the end of my rant
you want something in return but also I
feel like like when I rant like that
sometimes I'm like oh I think I need a
journal like when I rant and don't want
to response I'm like I think this was
supposed to be into a page to myself
yeah and then but like with Todd it's so
funny because I just love to talk so
much that he does not like 90% of the
time I don't need him to be listening I
just need his head to be near me while
I'm talking and then sometimes he's not
answering and I'm like hello do we have
any input and then he's like okay well
that that would really set me off I
think like someone not listening or
someone it's not that he's not listening
it's he's not like putting any input in
I'm like and then I'm like all right
well what do you think I should do we
have a game okay so we're going to play
Trash Tuesday's version of the Dr game
so the drele has four sides it's a top a
spinning top has four sides for trash
Tuesday's Dr game we have questions from
the fans from the Slugs that we got
today and you guys are going to spin and
whatever it lands on you guys have a
specific side that's dedicated to you
and gimmel means that all of you have to
answer the question got okay so grab
some uh dral underneath the manora so
Kila this how does Kila not let all of
the hate get to her I just let the hate
get to me no no um
hey you need to nun you need to nun um
no I mean you just there's no way for
certain things like that's an impossible
thing for nothing to get to you right
something's going to get to you and to
say that you're just above it all of you
you've risen and nothing hurts you
anymore is like so [__] delusional I
wish I could do that but no certain
things get to me but you just say it out
loud to yourself every morning you say
you know what I want to keep it pushing
I'm going to keep it pushing because I
like what I do I like what it affords me
in this life and I have the love of my
family my friends and um that's it
that's it like if you start to um kind
of lose focus of that I think that's
where you get in trouble but like I have
a lot of support and love in my life and
like that's what gets me through I I I
wish I could say oh it's all me and it's
all like my own like mental fortitude
but it's not like I have good people in
my life I have great therapist now I
have mushrooms and it really helps a lot
can't do mushrooms with you I was going
to say there's like um this bachelor uh
Clayton he was like a couple seasons ago
he's been like learning to dance and
posting these like and he's not like a
good dancer it's like really funny and
he's like I don't care I just express
myself but then he responds to every
comment and every comment is like that
makes fun of him he's like you think
it's cringe I don't but it's like you're
so affected by these comments but it's
kind of cute how he's like trying to
like positively overpower it's funny to
watch people deal with it all you you
you just honestly it's day by day cuz
some days I'll be like oh my God I want
to you know like it hurts a lot other
days you're like you don't even know it
exists cuz I'm underwater and also know
yourself more on someday you know what I
mean yeah but also like at the end at
the end of day I love myself I like who
I am I like who I've become in the last
couple years I like who I who I've been
I like who you are too thank you and I
just really go to bed at night thinking
you know what kalila you've harmed no
one today like you're a good person and
like you have a big heart and like
that's it like you just have to be okay
with who you are on the inside and I
think that gets you really far in life I
saw this thing where this guy was saying
like if someone came up and was yelling
at you like I don't say I'm not saying
this is true for you but for me it's
been helping me get out of it if someone
came up to you and was like your hair is
blue and it's ugly like how would you
like what would you would be like okay
crazy person my hair is not blue but
it's like so why am I taking on insults
that people are giving me it's like why
would I let my self-esteem be so much
less than like this random person's
opinion because sometimes being
misunderstood sucks it really sucks
especially when you can't do anything
about it for example like I posted I
used to when I thought that I wanted to
be a poet and I would post these poems
onto Instagram like a decade ago that
were written when I was like 17 18 they
were super super emo super embarrassing
but I was like you know what like I'm
just going to go through my little book
of poetry and post it gross but then now
there are people who are like this was
about Bob like they're breaking down my
poetry that I wrote when I was 17 18 and
like that's when that's when you're kind
of like you guys like really really like
you got it you got it all wrong you're
wrong about but the thing is the thing
is with what I've learned through kila's
sort of like plate in all this [__]
is like I obviously know the truth and
the truth has been said so many times
and you just realize like that with the
people that are trying to make up these
stories like we'll never be able to
control that narrative like they it's in
their head they're creating what they
want and it's like has nothing to do
with us they will only believe they will
only watch things that confirm the bias
their mind they're not going to watch or
believe like Bobby could straight up
look at these people in the face and be
like I did this to this girl I wanted
new [__] and give her give them the
facts and they would be like dude you
she probably did things for for for you
to do that to her so it's like it's
you're never going to win you have to
accept that you're never going to win
you're never going to take back what is
said about you and you just have to be
okay with yourself the people that who
who are in your life that support you
and that's just [__] it I kiss my
dogs every night and I hope the next day
you know is relatively
um okay and she doesn't jerk them off
okay guys with that this a funny thing
she said like a million years ago you
know it's also not forced a jerk off a
[__] dog by my family member when I
was like six and now apparently I'm into
beastiity I know you animals you're
animals this concept though is also not
exclusive to just like online or or
being in the public eye it's like you
can also there's people who just in
their workplace it's like they're
misunderstood by people or like someone
doesn't like them and there's 's nothing
they can do about it it's like this is
an everyday like in your life thing too
that we all have to just like the sooner
we can all like learn to just love
ourselves and and work on accepting
being misunderstood yeah the better can
I can I say what the up there is an
upside to all of this and the upside is
my whole life I've been a people pleaser
someone so driven by perception because
somehow I wanted um
to be told that I was lovable enough
that I was worth loving that um even so
much as a good job kalila my whole life
I've been striving for that because I
never got that from my parents right so
I'm somebody who people pleased my whole
life what this whole thing has forced me
to do is to do away with perception and
accepting that I am very polarizing that
some people will absolutely hate me some
people will love me and I am okay with
that as long as I am authentic and by
the way all the bad [__] are thank
you are so like that's like kind of like
oh I'm now it's broke my people pleasing
like Tendencies cuz it's like now I
don't even have control like I'm
literally hated by like a lot of these
men and I have no control of it so it's
like you're free [__] it I'm free that's
good I love that so my parents never
told me good job but that just made me
not ever need to hear good job oh really
know had a different what I don't I have
the opposite me too eser that's so
[__] cool that's so yeah you
basically no one ever was like no one
ever was like you're beautiful you're
talented like no compliment so it's like
strangers would say that to my mom would
go no like okay not wow Esther that's
you you almost kind of just like uh
rebelled against the trauma of it all I
just I I'm trying to figure out is it
like alcohol it just like wasn't in the
house like wasn't I think youd see like
I saw too many other people getting
maybe because we were playing sports you
would see other people getting like good
job so much that it was like wait why am
I not getting that and I'm doing the
best and somehow the people doing you
know worse than me are getting
celebrated by their parents I was doing
I was I was doing I was in the the woods
one day doing like a hike on a on a
weekend I was away and there was this
little family it was a bike trail and
they were like biking and this dad was
like two dads obviously they know how to
raise kids they were like so cute they
were the one daughter was like good job
like she was just like going so slow and
was like good job keep going and I was
like almost started crying I was like oh
that's exactly so now I'm like really
conscious of I have to like reparent
myself I have to tell myself all the
things that I wasn't I do seek some
validation you know like from Dave I'll
be like was this good but it doesn't
lead it's not people pleasing I do want
to I do want to do a good job I want to
put good work in like I wanted in high
school I always I wanted to get like the
leads and the plays I never got them I
wanted to do really well at dance but I
never it was always about like me and my
journey it was never about people
pleasing or like doing it for my parents
to think I was good like cuz that was
just not on the table like 90% of what I
did I did for usually a boy or like for
women and specifically to do things for
yourself yeah I didn't learn till 40 for
that but it is funny like I can kind of
tell what I'm missing by how impacted I
am when someone says it to me too my mom
randomly like I started doing like a lot
of work on myself and all my trauma and
my mom randomly sent me a a card that
just said to my sweet girl and I
realized she had never called me sweet
and I was like oh I have this idea that
I'm like rotten and bad and my mom
saying that I was like oh that's I need
to like fill my up my sweetness and like
acknowledge my sweetness and now Todd I
have a partner who like he calls he's
it's like so funny he's like good girl
like everything I do it's like so
hilarious like I'll be drinking water's
like you drinking your water good girl
it's like I love it I think Todd is
really good for um your inner child I
think that ultimately when I see you
guys I I think about like he gives you
all the things that maybe you didn't
realize that your younger self like
needed that safety that like positive
like reinforcement like I think it's so
sweet Dave ever said good girl to me I
would come in my pants on the spot like
that I know it's incredible wait a
second that is really hot yeah good girl
is good girl
my that's true I say good boy all the
time the fact that you're hearing that
when you drink water like I don't know
how you have the strength to just hand
to just be okay everything's wet I'm
very hydrated do I have to spin the I
think this is a very interesting
question that I would all like you to
answer what amount of lighting is the
best and the right lighting for sex I
have my answer but I need to just see a
silhouette and I need mostly Darkness I
don't need my body to be in full display
and the reason is I need to check out of
my surroundings I'm somebody who looks
at a ceiling and a crack and then I can
kind that can take me out so I need for
me to be in my body and in my feelings
my head has to be checked out so
Darkness does that for me I thought this
was a lightning round not the lighting
round I need the TV obviously the glare
of the TV um otherwise pitch black sound
yeah the sound I swear I need all of the
above sometimes it's a pitch black time
sometimes it's a full light sometimes
full light that's actually my default me
too Esther but yeah like I need to see I
need you to see I need to see like this
is what we're hiding this no but then
now you know 11 years in it's like it
makes it more exciting when you change
it up yeah sometimes it's like the
little sidelight like a candle I like
the danger of a house a candle would be
fun I should try that's kinky to me wa
you're right you're right variety yeah
variety is probably good but I do not
like like
fluorescent want to oh you never banged
anyone at a temp job eh little temp hump
do you have color changing bulbs any of
you I wish I did that's sound a strobe
light oh my God a strobe light and
you're like having a seizure but you're
also coming red light would be really
fun I would like that red and pink yeah
red light takes away all of the red
would be hot that would be like strip
club kind my friend told me that she was
like um G with her husband and they were
in a hotel and she like put like a thing
over the lamp and he was like don't do
that she's like no no it's fine and then
it did catch on fire while they were
banging kind of hot that's so funny that
was probably a really good she also burn
their house down at one point so I think
it might be her well Happy Hanukkah
happy Hanukkah to everyone out there who
observes Ryan locky mostly because we
just had some really good lockas I hope
you guys find yourself some Lockes it's
really hard to find anyone under 60 who
will make them for you so I wish you
well and good good luck and we wish you
a Julian in your life yeah it was so
good they're delicious I think it helps
if Jew is in their name honestly Julian
so we will see you guys next week with a
brand new episode and we love you and
happy trash Tuesday
[Music]
December